je suis ébloui je ne vous vois
pratiquement pas l'impression de parler
à personne donc lumière moderne
le team frontières deux aventures
spatiales au service de l'aventuré
humaine une évolution nécessaire une
évolution vital donc parcourir à travers
quelques images et à travers ce discours
les les étapes et les évolutions
nécessaires dans ce monde en permanence
en permanence bouleversement le 21e
siècle nous transporte dans cette sorte
de nébuleuse où s'affrontent de façon
systématique et de plus en plus
tumultueuses
les malheurs les bonheurs les joies les
désespoirs de l'homme moderne à la
recherche de ceux qui voudraient avoir
pour vivre mieux à la recherche d'une
meilleure santé à la recherche de tout
ce qui pourrait faire que cette
évolution incontournable l'amène à un
monde meilleur et son temps
progressivement cette orientation vers
une sorte d d'étouffement et se tourne
vers le vers le ciel comme l'ont fait
nos ancêtres mais cette fois avec des
outils qui lui permettent effectivement
de monter un peu un tout petit peu là
haut est d'essayer de comprendre si il y
trouvera les clés de ce qu'ils cherchent
actuellement pour améliorer son
existence alors qu'en fait tourner ce
truc-là frôlait ou transcender les
limites
alors dans ce petit diagramme qui
représente un siècle d'activités
humaines dans la troisième dimension
vous voyez à peu près au milieu ou d'une
cinquantaine d'années un grand événement
donc là l'arrivée sur la lune donc une
ascension fulgurante
et puis et ben le l'obstacle n'a pas été
transcendé l'essai n'a pas été
transformé et puis le voyage suivant qui
devait nous conduire sur mars il se fait
attendre il ya des chances qu'il se
fasse attendre encore pendant longtemps
et nous sommes redescendus n'ont pas
transformé l'essai nous sommes perplexes
et en fait dans les 50 années qui ont
suivi nous avons nous avons fait face à
beaucoup de réalités je parle près pas
de difficulté mais de réalité et c'est
cet homme enthousiaste et conquérant qui
était parti donc tu es le début de cette
aventure spatiale
eh bien il devenu un homme plus moderne
plus simple toujours aussi enthousiaste
l'ecc a dû réaliser à travers certaines
relations scientifiques à travers
certains discours certaines informations
comme celles que nous venons d'avoir et
bien que le les pas suivants devraient
être fait ou non du peuple de la terre
ne s'agissait plus d'aller planter un
drapeau sur une planète mais agir en
solidarité avec ce peuple de la terre
qui ne trouvera les créer 2 c'est alors
je regarde où j'en suis comme des clés
de cette nouvelle aventure à qu'au
travers d'une paix globale et d'une paix
universelle
pas si tu as une belle planète et tous
reconnu jupiter explorateur de la
possible la lumière manque rethel dans
la suite de tout cela l'a donc ce que
l'on constate que les les pas du futur
la progression le progrès de l'aventuré
spatiale
on ne parle plus de conquête on parle
d'une exploration de l'espace ne peut se
faire sans être dissociée de du progrès
du peuple de du peuple de la terre alors
on nous demande et sept défis d'un côté
le défi des explorateurs de l'espace et
le déchets de l'humanité sont
complètement imbriqués beaucoup plus que
jamais on nous demande en quoi votre
aventure donc on revient vraiment un peu
trop en arrière est ce que votre
aventure sert à quelque chose dans ce
sens dans ce sens de cette coopération
alors évidemment je vais pas vous dire
non et vous dirais que l'équipe la
grande équipe internationale qui a été
conçu autour du projet de station
spatiale internationale réunie une
réalisation brillante dirais pas
grandiose mais exemplaire en ce sens que
cette équipe qui a été capable en vingt
ans de monter cet arsenal là haut a été
surtout capable de faire fonctionner eu
plusieurs équipes internationales donc
de vaincre de très nombreux obstacles
soaked acte géographique l'obstacle de
la langue des obstacles culture des
obstacles de leurs connaissances
technologiques leurs habitudes et vers
cette équipe fonctionne parfaitement
bien a su s'affranchir de beaucoup de
barrières et a donc franchi ce grand pas
qui est à mon avis à l'avis de beaucoup
je pense
capable non pas de servir de modèles
mais d'exemples de ce qui peut être fait
toujours autour de cette notion d'un
peuple de la terre qui veut avancer et
qui veut aller voir plus loin
le cette notion est d'autant plus
essentiel que nos scientifiques nous
révèlent tous les jours l'existence de
pas moins d'un milliard pratiquement 1
milliard d'exoplanètes de planètes
similaires à la terre dans notre seule
galaxie donc notre grain de sable pour
reprendre l'expression de mes
prédécesseurs notre grain de sable est
bien trop petit pour au milieu de cette
foultitude de planètes semblables est
trop petit pour contenir les milliers de
frontières les milliers de clocher les
milliers d'idées qu'on ne veut pas
partager et 7
ce repli sur soi qui est le comportement
humain actuel ça ne passe plus ça ne
passe plus dans ce monde dans ce bon là
on a plus de viser de belles images de
l'univers on va en avoir tout à l'heure
mais ne peut plus contenir ce genre de
grains de sable découpé en micro grain
de sable et des exemples d'avancé
internationale il n'y a pas que le il
n'y a pas que cette équipe
internationale de l' iss on a aussi eu
heureusement de nombreuses associations
culturelles scientifiques etc qui
fonctionne très bien sur notre planète
et ce ne sont pas des mouvements
internationaux à vocation politique
il ya là aussi je n'entrerai pas dans ce
détail on n'a pas le temps pis pense que
ça serait déplacé des ya aussi le
problème politique il n'y avait au temps
on a une amorce de mouvements
internationaux
autant on n'a pas de la mort ce d'une
politique dax
politiques internationaux on vit
toujours dans le haut clocher dans nos
casernes et là il ya un effort à faire
le bon exemple de cette équipe
internationale et un petit mot
maintenant avant de passer au stade
suivant les choisit donc l'image de la
lumière pour cet événement d'aujourd'hui
qui dansa dans son côté abstrait
immatériel et rapide et une excellente
introduction à ses limites de bons que
que nous voudrions passer aujourd'hui
alors voyez belles dents dans l'univers
on va avoir quelques chiffres mais avant
toute chose je regarde si le voilà alors
je sais pas est ce que vous voyez ici
dans cette nébuleuse quelque chose qui
vous rappellent autre chose on vous met
sur la piste ce matin là il ya une
langue bahianais il ya deux yeux des
cheveux un peu leur suite d'une touche
de cheveux ici qui bon il ya trouvé
einstein mais on on va le voir après
alors des chiffres à la vitesse de la
lumière
un dixième de seconde pour faire le tour
de la terre il seconde pour rejoindre la
banlieue lunaire suivie minute pour mars
quatre années l'étoile la plus proche
trois cent mille ans pour traverser
notre galaxie à peu près et quelques
millions d'années pour les envois une
autre est là donc on verra ce petit
montage le pas extraordinaire ça
cette grande nébuleuse regardez bien il
disparaît vous avez bien les yeux la
bouffe le nez les cheveux la touffe de
cheveux ici voilà donc alors on va aller
on va revenir un peu sur terre et des
vitesses pareil en une vie humaine
qu'est ce qu'on ferait si on a la chance
de voyager à la vitesse de la lumière
je vais essayer de pas bouger trop on
franchir est à peu près le diamètre de
ce petit point à ce qu'on ferait donc il
y a quelque chose qui nous choque qu'on
avance la technologie avance la science
avance mais on en est toujours à des
limites des limites
graff reprendre les expressions de
jeunes alors un autre petit exemple pour
nous divertir un peu avant la fin on a
imaginé un voyageur intelligent gens
intelligents ce voyageur conçu de nos
jours au 21e siècle et qu'on enverrait
comme ça à l'exploration de l'univers
et si on envoyait vers une autre galaxie
mais mettrait quelques millions d'années
pour y aller mais avant qu'il nous
envoie son message
lorsque même pas la peine d'y penser
donc on s'est dit que des gens
intelligents on l'envoie à 50 mille
années-lumière seulement à l'intérieur
de notre galaxie
ce pas très loin 58 les lire mais comme
il n'a pas encore atteint la vitesse de
la lumière il va mettre à peu près 150
mille ans pour y aller et puis cinquante
mille ans pour nous renvoyer le message
au total deux cent mille ans c'est à peu
près un peu moins que l'âge de lui
mérité je suis pas trompé c'est bien ça
de sens bien donc son message retour on
aura dans deux sens mieux donc pour
concrétiser un peu tout seul lors ne
trompe de boutons que dirions-nous de
l'image réfléchie d'un miroir aura été
envoyés sur la lune à l'époque de
léonard de vinci etc et monette époque
le mirror seraient arrivés il ya un mois
et leur enverrai une belle image de la
terre eh bien on dirait on dirait ben
oui mais c'est pas la bonne couleur
bon pour le musée
donc toujours qu'on vous mette un peu
sur le appétit de découverte
j'espère que les élèves de l'école des
mines des mines dans quelques temps
arriverons à nous trouver les réponses à
ces questions qu'on se pose alors
rapidement le chemin du destin a ses
limites
où en sommes-nous un autre petit
diagramme alors ici 15 milliards
d'années l'âge de l'univers
et si on prend cette échelle ça nous
amène ça nous amène ça nous amène très
loin par là et ce qui nous intéresse
donc on passe les autres non le soleil
etc
et puis 6 millions d'années 6 millions
d'années ça nous amène sur cette route 6
millions d'années c'est un deux
millièmes de l'âge de l'univers
je me suis pas trompé vient le 2000e oui
1 2 1000e 6 millions d'années 1 2
millièmes de l'âge l'univers et c'est
pourtant loin derrière vous c'est là
qu'il ya le premier bipèdes de même pas
un ancêtre de l'homme mais puis en
remontant monta remonte en live à 2 300
milles en homo sapiens au mode l'homme
de néandertal et c'est nous l'a310 donc
est ce que nous sommes
une étincelle à l'échelle de ces 15
milliards d'années il est un seul
capable d'allumer un grand brasier
puis on n'en parle plus peu comme
utiliser le pape tout à l'heure où une
étincelle qui va allumer une grande
lumière grande lumière moderne qui va se
poursuivre loin par là par la passion à
vos yeux
le voilà donc toujours dans les temps
alors on revient un petit peu en arrière
et imaginons condé on soit capable
actuellement 2 x 400 la vitesse maximum
que nous atteignons aujourd'hui qui est
de mac' 25 c'est à dire 7 km par seconde
bon 400 fois ça nous donnerait un
centième de la vitesse de la lumière
c'est quand même pas mal trois kits
trois mille kilomètres par seconde
ça mettrait la lune à deux minutes de
10,6
et 10 à 15 heures un voyage
transatlantique donc 10 à 15 heures pour
atteindre mars
eh ben et encore quatre siècles pour
être atteindre l'étoile la plus proche
donc toujours un peu loin alors je saute
quelques autres idées que j'avais pas ce
que voit que le temps passe alors pour
en savoir plus on a décidé d'aller
écouter aux portes et on se pose la
question puisqu'on n'arrive pas aller
assez vite posé question est-ce qu'on a
des voisins
donc on écoute écoute aux portes en
était que les voisins vont pouvoir nous
envoyer des trucs pour améliorer notre
ordinaire donc je vous passe les
chiffres on est parti d'une vous allez
devoir on arrive à un voyage impossible
1 milliard d'exoplanètes dans notre
galaxie
et puis tout cela je vous laisse le
passer on imagine donc y est c'est mille
à mille civils isation par par galaxie
et qui ont pu commencer à exister
disons il ya dix milliards d'années et
puis qui émettent leur fameux signal et
c'est très sérieux on a pas d'endroit
sur la terre maintenant on écoute on ne
sait trop les hobbies peux vous dire on
n'a toujours rien entendu et et puis on
fait un petit calcul statistique de
probabilité je vous laisse faire on
arrive au résultat il reste tu as fait
une chance sur dix mille à peu près dont
on écrit si tenté qu'il y ait un signal
donc là aussi pas de bol les voisins
vont rien nous dire
donc voilà je suis dans les temps
on arrive à la conclusion donc cette
immensité n'a pas été fait pour qu'on se
contente de le regarder
c'est là la version optimiste nous
sommes nés pour survivre à ce besoin
on va exprimer un premier slide mais
pour nous battre contre l'ignorance
tout ça s'est fait partie aussi du
message que vous avez entendu tout à
l'heure mais pour gagner et on reprend
le petit tremplin de tout à l'heure ça
ressemble un plongeoir
donc là on allonneau zola nos eaux
basses et là c'est les deux cent mille
ans quand même et je sais vraiment rien
c'est le le dernier millimètre du
plongeoir
alors après ces poids il ya là l'option
on va commencer par la pessimiste la
pessimiste passé ils passent le rabot me
tombe là et puis de la version optimiste
c'est par là
l'étincelle ont rallumé non pas un
incendie mais une belle lumière moderne
répugnant n'arrivera peut-être tout
d'autres sont arrivés que c'est pour ça
qu'on n'a pas leurs signaux pour ça une
grande transcendance un passage à une
autre forme de présence de civilisation
mais quand même il faudra pas mal de bol
voilà dépassés
[Applaudissements]